the world has had just a few days to
process the impact of 01 preview from
open Ai and I have used that time to
read or in a couple of cases reread
seven papers I think help explain what
01 is and what's coming next I'll also
draw on talks released earlier today to
back up the claim that I made a few days
ago the 01 preview represents a step
change in how models are trained and
what they can do of course I'll also
remind you of what they can't yet do
even if they thought about it for the
length of this entire video here at
least is what one top open AI researcher
thinks I didn't expect he said there to
be much time where there's two totally
different roughly intelligence matched
winning on different dimensions species
but that seems pretty clearly where
we're at to be honest I just wanted to
use this tweet to set the stage for the
special moment we're in in AI here is
what I think open AI did at a very high
level with the 01 series of models as
the video progresses I'll get even more
granular with my reasoning and quote
paragraphs from three-year-old papers to
back it up but for those who want a big
picture overview here's what I think
they've done the foundational original
objective of language models is to model
language it's to predict the next word
you can think of that if you like as
Paradigm one interesting but not overly
useful ask a question and the language
model might predict another question to
follow it so to simplify again we
brought in another objective Paradigm 2
we wanted models to be honest harmless
and helpful we or more like a proxy for
us would give rewards to the models When
It produced outputs that met those
objectives we started get answers that
weren't just likely from a probability
perspective but also sometimes harmless
honest and helpful enter chat GPT and I
hear that's doing well 01 for me at
least represents Paradigm 3 we want to
reward answers that are objectively
correct not saying that we've forgotten
the original objectives but we've
layered another one on top of them but
how did they actually do that well again
I'm going to give you the one minute
summary and then go into more detail
later in the video most of us might be
aware that you can get models to Output
what's called a Chain of Thought by
asking models for example to think step
by step you can get much longer outputs
that have reasoning steps within them
but that Secret's already a few years
old so that's not what is special about
01 so people thought of a brilliant idea
that just didn't quite work how about we
feed the model thousands of examples of
human step-by-step reasoning well yes
that does work but it's not really
optimal it doesn't scale super well open
AI realized you could go One Step better
so I'm going to hand the mic to them for
30 seconds when we think about like
training a model for reasoning one thing
that immediately jumps to mind is you
could have humans write out their
thought process and train on that um
when aha moment for me was like when we
saw that if you train the model using RL
to generate and own its own genain of
thoughts it can do even better than
having humans right Chain of Thought for
it and that was an aha moment that you
could really scale this uh and explore
models reasoning directly wait so it's
better to train on model generated
chains of thought but how come they're
so often wrong and what does he mean by
reinforcement learning in this context
well how about this and here clearly I'm
going to get slightly metaphorical how
about we go up to the model and whisper
in its ear get really creative don't
worry as much about predicting the next
word super accurately I just want really
diverse outputs from you the model of
course at what's called a temperature of
one is more than happy to get created
and generate loads of diverse chains of
thought meanwhile other researchers must
be looking on at these guys thinking
what are they doing these are going to
be so unreliable but then what if we had
a way preferably automatically of
grading those outputs then even many of
you might agree well some of those
outputs are going to be good especially
with more and more time spent thinking
longer and longer chains of thought
doesn't matter how low a proportion of
the outputs are correct as long as we
get at least one or a few then out of
those those thousands of outputs we can
take those that work those that produce
the correct answer in mathematics
science coding we take that answer and
we fine-tune the model on those correct
answers with correct reasoning steps
that's how this becomes reinforcement
learning only the best outputs are
making it through to the next round and
being used to further train the model
and because you're only fine-tuning or
further training on those correct
outputs with correct reasoning steps
this process is highly data efficient
unlike training on the web where it
might include one of your random Reddit
comments which were awful by the way or
a tweet you did a few years ago this is
golden data so notice then how it's a
marriage of train time compute the
fine-tuning or training of a model and
what's called test time compute that
thinking time test time if you weren't
clear is when the model is actually
outputting something not when it's being
trained we already knew that giving the
models the time to produce what's called
serial calculations one after another
after another before producing their
final output would boost results that
kind of makes sense right especially in
technical domains and that's what we've
seen But then marry that with train time
compute training on those correct
generations and then you get these two
scaling graphs for this difficult
mathematics competition more time to
think equals better results but then
train or fine-tune the model or
generator on correct outputs and
reasoning steps and that also produces a
noticeable increase and as you may have
noticed neither of those graphs look
like they are particularly leveling off
anytime soon before I get into those
seven juicy papers that I mentioned at
the start I do want to touch on a bigger
question that many of you might have
which is is this reasoning does it count
as humanlike intelligence well it's
definitely not humanlike but it might
not ultimately matter the analogy I came
up with was this think of a librarian
you're going up to this librarian
because you have a question you want
answered the library books here are the
models training data and the original
chat gbt was a very friendly librarian
but it would often bring you the wrong
book or maybe it would bring you the
right book that could answer your
question but point to the wrong
paragraph within that book it was clear
that chat was decent as a librarian but
had no no idea what it was handing to
you it was pretty easy if you wanted to
to demonstrate that it wasn't actually
intelligent the 01 series of models are
much better Librarians they've been
taking notes on what books successfully
answered the questions that guess had
and which ones didn't down to the level
not just of the book but the chapter the
paragraph and the line we are still left
though of course with the fundamental
question but the librarian doesn't
actually understand what it's presenting
this though is when things get
philosophically murky does it ultimately
matter in the end we don't even
understand how the human brain works
frankly I'm going to leave this one to
you guys and you can let me know what
you think in the comments but one thing
is clear from this metaphor which is if
you ask a question about something
that's not in the models training data
that's not in the library then doesn't
matter what you think the librarian will
screw up by the way the librarian is
exceptionally unlikely to say I don't
know and instead we'll bring you an
irrelevant book that weakness of course
is still incred rly prevalent in 01
preview and there is another hurdle that
would follow if you agree with this
analysis not just a lack of training
data what about domains that have plenty
of training data but no clearly correct
or incorrect answers then you would have
no way of sifting through all of those
chains of thought and fine-tuning on the
correct ones compared to the original
GPT 40 in domains with correct and
incorrect answers largely you can see
the performance boost in areas with
harder to disting correct or incorrect
answers much less of a boost in fact a
regress in personal writing so that's
the big picture but now time for the
juicy details and hidden hints we've
seen over the last few days but before
that I hope you'll forgive me for Just 2
minutes about me and the channel and
when I say that I'm grateful for
comments and for watching to the end I
really do mean it it's an honor to take
a small parcel of your time and I don't
expect any support beyond that when I
launched AI insiders late last year on
patreon it was my attempt though at
keeping the channel financially viable
as I had permanently given up running my
previous business around mid last year I
picked a price frankly that I thought it
was worth which was $29 and I was
honestly moved that people signed up and
stayed steady for almost a year these
guys are truly my Spartans and many of
you will be watching but yes of course I
read the emails of people saying it was
just a bit too much money for them and
they couldn't quite afford it so 9
months on I have decided to take what
you could call a gamble with my entire
career and reduce the price
significantly from $29 a month to $9 a
month all in or actually with an annual
sub discount
$756 a month now just quickly to
encourage my dedicated supporters to
stay on that higher tier I will be
keeping the unfiltered personal podcast
exclusive to that original $29 tier and
to anyone who stays at that tier I will
personally message you with thanks also
I do that for every new person joining
that tier but to everyone else for whom
$9 a month is viable let me finish these
two quick minutes with a tour what you
get access to is exclusive AI explained
videos I think there's around 30 of them
now like this one from last night on
that Humanity's last exam or Benchmark
that people were talking about yesterday
exact same quality that you would expect
and you get explainers like this one on
the origins of the term AGI obviously
people comment as they do on YouTube and
on and on you can also download each
video so you can watch it offline if you
want to for those $9 or $7 you also get
access to the Discord which has evolved
a lot since it started now has live
meetups a new book club and of course
General discussion if you go to the
introductions page you can see the
caliber of the kind of people who join
on Discord some people of course won't
care about any of that and will just
want to support hype-free AI journalism
in a landscape I wrote that increasingly
needs it totally understand by the way
if $9 is too much I am just super
grateful for you watching back to 01
though and one thing you might have
noticed is we can't actually see those
chains of thought if you've used 01 for
sure you do see a summary and of course
the output but not the true chains of
thought that led it to that output open
AI admits that part of the reason for
for that is their own competitive
advantage and if you have followed the
analysis so far that would kind of make
sense rival Labs especially those that
don't care much about terms and
conditions could train on successful
chains of thought that were outputed by
the 01 series after all that is the key
ingredient to its success so it makes
sense but even if we can't see those
chains of thought they have clearly
unlocked much better serial calculations
imagine you had to square a number
multiple times in a row it's really hard
to do that in parallel isn't it you kind
of need to know the result of the first
calculation before you can do the next
one well with a really long scratch pad
to work things out on or a Chain of
Thought that's hidden models get much
better at that that ability to break
down long or confusing questions into a
series of small computational steps is
why I think that 01 preview gets
questions like these correct most of the
time as people have been pointing out to
me now I'm very much aware of that fact
because I analyzed every single answer
the 01 preview gave as I said in my last
video when I benchmarked it initially on
simple bench but that whole thing of
just sneaking in a fact amongst many
others as you might see in this question
when she eats three other cookies that's
just one small component of simple bench
there Still Remains many many question
categories where it flops badly again
because the data is not in its training
data the librarian can't retrieve a book
that's not there the makers of Ark AGI
amongst the most popular AI benchmarks
say this in summary 01 represents a
paradigm shift from memorize the answers
to memorize the reasoning remember it
was trained on those reasoning steps
that did end up leading to a correct
answer so it's starting to get better at
recognizing which kinds of reasoning
lead to correct answers in which domain
less do I have that exact fact exact
answer in my training data and more do I
have the kind of reasoning steps that I
think might be a appropriate for solving
this problem but still as I think I've
made clear in this video If those
reasoning steps or facts are not in the
training data they're not in
distribution it still will fail 01 is
still not a departure from the broader
Paradigm of fitting a curve to a
distribution in order to boost
performance by making everything in
distribution training on everything
expanding the library they say we still
need new ideas for artificial general
intelligence another way of putting this
is that there doesn't exist a foundation
model for the physical world we don't
have those Banks and banks of quote
correct answers for real world tasks and
that's partly why models flop on simple
bench so you should start to notice a
pattern in those questions that 01
preview is now getting right where GPT
40 couldn't one of the stars of 01 gnome
Brown of open AI gave this example it
came from the famous Professor Ral that
I interviewed on this channel and
actually for insiders it's about
stacking blocks and it's quite confusing
at first but 01 preview gets it nicely
this by the way was originally given as
an example of the kind of problems that
llm simply can't get right but I
wouldn't say that stacking blocks is a
data sparse kind of domain it's just
that previous models got overwhelmed
with the amount of things going on it
just required too many serial
calculations and computations and they
couldn't do it and if you want more
evidence that training data for better
or ill dictates performance here's an
example with o1 preview the surgeon who
is the boy's father says I can't operate
on this boy he's my son who is the
surgeon to the boy remember he's been
described as the boy's father but the
surgeon is the boy's other father the
boy has two Fathers as always then it's
worth remembering that exam style
knowledge benchmarks in particular
rather than true reasoning benchmarks
does not equal real world capabilities I
now want to count down 10 more
interesting facts and bits of background
about 01 before I end on where we all go
from here what comes next first as you
may have gathered the training of 01 was
fundamentally different from GPT 4 that
extra layer of reinforcement learning
means that no amount of prompt
engineering on the base GPT 40 no amount
of asking for thinking step by step will
be able to match its performance next is
the 01 preview and 01 might be piecing
together reasoning steps that we haven't
pieced together before there still quote
are reasoning steps but the model is
optimized to piece together those steps
that achieve the desired result as one
of the key authors of 01 who I talked
about a lot last year Lucas Kaiser said
when you know the right Chain of Thought
you can compute anything and as Andre
karpathy said two days ago those
thoughts don't even need to be legible
to us they might piece together
reasoning steps that are translated from
other languages or are in their own
madeup language remember that the
objective is now clearly to get the
right answer so the models will optimize
however they can to do so and my next
point is as gome brown points out this
is exactly what happened with chess
indeed the way he says it is this is
starting to sound a lot like referring
to 01 min's performance in the code
forces contest it's starting to sound a
lot like the trajectory of Chess which
was what well I'm obviously
oversimplifying here but stockfish the
best chess model was trained originally
with
humanistics handcrafted functions to
evaluate board positions obviously it
used search to assess way more positions
than a human could but it still had
those handcrafted functions well until
July 2023 stockfish removed the
handcrafted evaluation and transitioned
to a fully neural network based approach
or to put it another way by crafting its
own reasoning steps and being optimized
to put them together in the most
effective fashion we may end up with
reasoning that we ourselves couldn't
have come up with as long as there is
something out there that can grade
correct versus incorrect the performance
will keep improving for the next series
of interesting points I'm going to draw
on a video I made 9 months ago obviously
I am ridiculously biased but I think it
was absolutely bang on in terms of its
predictions about qar honestly if you
got time I recommend watching this
entire video but I'm going to pick out a
handful of moments where I really called
it but that's not the important bit it's
where it helps explain that these
researchers saw what is coming 9 months
12 months ago the clues were out there
we just had to put them together so my
fourth interesting point comes from
minute 17 of the video where this
approach of emitting chains of thought
can be extended into different
modalities mul where the Tain of thought
is basically a simulation of of the
world so it will be multimodality and
disability to generate sequences of
things before you give an answer that
that will resemble much more what we
call reasoning that was a short snippet
but I think contains a crucial detail
just like the 01 family of models is
scoring dramatically better in physics
tests Sora the video generation model
from open AI could get way better at
modeling physics in pixels it could
attempt to predict the next pixel with
chains of thought and be fine-tuned on
those predictions that actually worked
potentially without even needing a data
labeling Revolution a video generation
model could learn which sources which
videos from YouTube for example depict
reality with the most accuracy as one
former googler and open AI member
Jeffrey Irving said you could have a
scenario of let's think pixel by pixel
this step change in other words doesn't
have to be limited to text now for my
next point point I have no idea why I
delayed it this long into the video but
look at this prediction that I made back
in November I picked out a key paragraph
in a paper called let's verify step by
step which indicated what open AI we
working on let's verify step by step
could be like choosing an action after
all in the original paper using test
time compute in this way was described
as a kind of search and in let's verify
they hinted at a step forward involving
reinforcement learning they said we do
not attempt to improve prove the
generator the model coming up with
Solutions with reinforcement learning we
do not discuss any supervision the
generator would receive from the reward
model if trained with RL and here's the
key sentence although fine-tuning the
generator with reinforcement learning is
a natural next step it is intentionally
not the focus of this work is that the
follow-up work that they did I mean if
that prediction isn't worthy of a like
on YouTube or preferably joining AI
insiders then I don't know what is I
then went into detail on the 2022 paper
that showed how that would be done in a
nutshell it involves fine-tuning a model
on the outputs it generated that happen
to work keep going until you generate
rationals that get the correct answer
and then fine tune on all of those
rationals and they say that we show that
star significantly improves performance
on multiple data sets compared to a
model fine-tuned to directly predict
final answers does that remind you of
let's verify and performs comparably to
fine-tuning a 30X larger
state-of-the-art language model next I
want to show you all a warning straight
from ilas satova one of the key authors
of this approach presumably he's putting
it to work in the safe super
intelligence company but he had a
warning reinforcement learning is
creative reinforcement learning has a
much more significant
challenge it is
creative reinforcement learning is
actually
creative all the stun every single
stunning example of creativity in AI
comes from a reinforcement learning
system for example Alpha zero has
invented a whole new way of playing a
game that humans have perfected for
thousands of years it is reinforcement
learning that can come up Creative
Solutions to problems solutions which we
which we might not be able to understand
at all and so what happens if you do
reinforcement learning on long or even
medium time Horizon when you AI is
interacting with the real
world trying to achieve some kind of a
beneficial outcome let's say as judged
by us but while being very very very
creative this does not mean that this
problem is unsolvable but it means that
it is a problem and it means that some
of the more naive approaches will suffer
from some unexpected creativity that
will make the antics of Sydney seem very
modest next I feel I foreshadowed qar
strawberry or o one's weakness with
spatial reasoning I think the
development is likely a big step forward
for narrow domains like mathematics but
is in no way yet a solution for AGI the
world is still a bit too complex for
this to work yet that desperate need to
model the world's complexity and Achieve
true spatial intelligence is why fa Le's
startup is already worth $1 billion
after Just 4 months now as I've hinted
already in this video I think open AI
graded the individual reasoning steps of
the generator's outputs not just whether
the overall answer was correct but for
more background on that it would be
easier for me to just play a couple of
minutes from that November 2023 video in
which by the way I site a June 2023
video from this channel so that's test
time computes but what about let's
verify step by step well going back to
that original 2021 verifier paper they
said this the problem that they noticed
with their approach back in 2021 was
that their models were rewarding correct
Solutions but some sometimes there would
be false positives getting to the
correct Final Answer using flawed
reasoning they knew this was a problem
and so they worked on it and then in May
of this year they came out with let's
verify step by step in this paper by
getting a verifier or reward model to
focus on the process the P instead of
the outcome the O results were far more
dramatic next notice how the graph is
continuing to rise if they just had more
let's say test time comput this could
continue Rising higher and I actually
speculated on that back on June the 1st
that difference of about 10% is more
than half of the difference between gpt3
and GPT 4 and also is it me or is that
line continuing to grow suggesting that
when more compute is available the
difference could be even more Stark
imagine a future where GPT 4 or 5 can
sample say a trillion 10 to the 12
Solutions so you're beginning to see my
hypothesis emerging a new improved let's
verify step by step called qar Drawing
upon enhanced inference time compute to
push the graph toward 100% if you want
more details on that process reward
model check out the video I did back
then called double the performance but
the very short version is that they
trained a reward model to notice the
individual steps in a reasoning sequence
that reward model then got very good at
spotting erroneous steps furthermore
when that model concluded that there
were no erroneous steps as we've seen
from the graphs that was highly
indicative of a correct solution notice
also that sometimes it could pick out
such a correct solution when the
original generator gp4 only outputed
that correct solution one time in a
thousand furthermore the method somewhat
generalized out of distribution going
Beyond mathematics to boost performance
in chemistry physics and other subjects
and gome brown I think gave a clear hint
that verifies were used in the training
of 01 again my theory is the only
answers for which every reasoning step
was correct and The Final Answer were
used to train or fine-tune the 01 family
but just look at this point he leaves
hanging in the air after showing the
famous let's verify graph if you do this
process reward models where you're
verifying every single step with a
really good reward model you're getting
an even bigger boost and you're getting
up to 78.2% and you can see it still
looks like that that number that line is
would go up more if you generate more
samples
that's as big a hint as you're going to
get that let's verify was key 401 and
very quickly before I leave let's verify
don't forget that that paper cited work
from Google some of the other key
authors behind and around let's verify
have also gone to anthropic so it's not
like openai will be the only ones
working on this yes they're well ahead
but I could well see one of those other
two Labs catching up and do you remember
early in this video I talked about how
higher temperature was optimal for
generating those creative chains of
thought well that was suggested as early
as 2021 at openai from the paper I cited
in that November 2023 video I talked
about this paragraph verification
consists of sampling multiple high
temperature Solutions and then it goes
on about verification you might be
wondering where I'm going with this but
that is why I think the API of the 01
family keep the temperature at one I
think the model itself was used to to
generate those chains of thought and
then that same model was then fine-tuned
on those correct Solutions in other
words because the model was trained that
way is optimal to keep the temperature
at one open AI don't actually allow you
to change it let me know in the comments
if you think I've figured out something
there anyway those were the facts and
the White House is certainly taking all
of this quite seriously they were shown
strawberry and 01 earlier this year and
they now describe how AI data center
development and promoting it and funding
it reflects the importance of these
projects to American National Security
and economic interests the government at
the very least is a Believer but are we
well I have been very impressed by 01
preview let me know if you have thank
you so much for watching I would love to
see you over on AI insiders but either
way please do have a wonderful day